[Música]
actualizamos la economía en directo
américa jorge hurtado ya nos acompaña
nuevamente en el estudio jorge varias
importantes navieras anunciaron la
suspensión de envíos hacia y desde rusia
así de raúl - la naviera maers es la
última que se suma a las navieras del
mundo que ya han impuesto algunas
restricciones en el transporte marítimo
contra rusia en respuesta a esta
invasión a ucrania la suspensión abarca
todos los puertos rusos aunque no
incluirá productos alimenticios ni
suministros médicos y humanitarios la
medida de esta empresa sigue la de otras
como hoy en network express con sede en
singapur la alemana hapag lloyd y la del
grupo naviero suizo ms c-max posee el 31
por ciento del operador portuario ruso
global ports que trabaja en 6 terminales
en rusia y 2 en finlandia la naviera
tiene unos 500 empleados en rusia y la
semana pasada suspendido de forma
temporal
en las escalas en ucrania donde tiene
160 empleados en odessa la compañía de
controla alrededor del 17% de la flota
mundial
de contenedores las cadenas de
suministros de por sí afectadas por los
bloqueos post pandemia viven ahora una
presión por la invasión rusa en ucrania
desde el inicio del conflicto en los
tres buques mercantes fueron
bombardeados y las aseguradoras se
niegan a dar cobertura a los que navegan
por el mar negro o exigen enormes primas
para poder hacerlo y el bloque europeo
impuso sanciones contra varios son
magnates de ese ruso jorge así es y
bueno estas sanciones que se han
impuesto a los magnates rusos
curiosamente no han sido impuestas por
eeuu entre ellos está el magnate de los
metales alisher usmánov los propietarios
de alfa group mikel fredman y per avn
además de alexei mordashóv que controla
una importante empresa siderúrgica según
bloomberg la unión europea trabaja en
otras medidas para alcanzar a más
multimillonarios rusos con sus sanciones
otro de los sancionados es dimitir
pescado para el portavoz de vladimir
putin y un amigo íntimo del presidente
ruso el violonchelista sergio roldán
uno de los sancionados respondieron
inmediatamente a través de comunicados
de prensa diciendo que las acusaciones
son infundadas en teorías conspirativas
y fantasías históricas y ante todo esto
que está pasando en rute los ciudadanos
hicieron filas en las casas de cambio
jorge así es bueno en san petersburgo la
segunda ciudad más grande de rusia la
gente observaba la tabla de anuncios de
divisas viendo caer el rublo entre las
principales monedas o frente a las
principales monedas del mundo y esto era
parte de lo que comentaba las personas
que estaban ahí tratando de hacer sus
cambios
y hay mucha gente que no entiende en qué
dirección está llevando nuestro gobierno
la economía y todo en general no habrá
orden
todo era predecible porque las acciones
de putin son siempre las mismas esto es
el fascismo y el genocidio de ucrania y
sólo empeorará versus raúl hubo filas
también en el aeropuerto de domodédovo
cerca de moscú donde varios turistas
europeos quedaron varados estudiantes
extranjeros o rusos que salen del país
ya sea por negocios o vacaciones
vivieron la cancelación de sus vuelos
después de que las naciones de europa
cerrarán su espacio aéreo a los aviones
rusos por la invasión de ucrania y como
parte de esta batería de sanciones que
se han impuesto a rusia ni los civiles
como siempre jorge los más afectados por
las decisiones de unos pocos indicadores
empezamos con las bolsas asiáticas que
cerraron en positivo haciendo una pausa
a las ventas masivas que sacudieron los
mercados financieros del mundo tras la
invasión rusa de ucrania la semana
pasada mientras que la subida de los
precios del petróleo apoyo a los
exportadores de la región en europa las
bolsas europeas cayeron iniciando marzo
con una nota sombría debido a la
debilidad de los informes de resultados
y el nerviosismo que existe en torno al
en ruso en ucrania jorge y para
finalizar ya este último bloque
económico de la mañana cifra el día
bueno la cifra del día tiene que ver
también con este conflicto y hablamos
específicamente del bitcoin que se ubica
en 43 mil 528 dólares cada uno el
bitcoin aumentó un 6 por ciento en medio
de la crisis en un craneal la mayor
cripto de visas pues ha ganado terreno
pese a la incertidumbre que se vive en
los mercados financieros pero después de
los 66 mil algo así y no vimos algo
igual todavía no sabes muchísimas
gracias entonces como siempre por toda
la información el comunicó económica nos
vemos mañana con más pasamos directo a
parís